uh my name is jules i'm a developer
advocate the lead develop advocate for
indie scale innisfail is a company that
manages these
managed service array how many people
actually heard about ray
well you guys can leave then if you have
but no um like i said i i before i
before i uh
joined any scale i was at databricks for
about six years so i was doing the same
thing with in terms of uh scaling
data at scale
and today's talk is about ray how do you
actually scale your machine learning
applications we have sort of entered the
zeiss guide stuff for ml and what does
it actually mean to scale your
application
so
today's agenda um what i'm going to do
is i'm going to start at 20 000 feet and
we're going to go down to 10 000 feet
we're going to go down to zero feet
above the sea level we're going to look
at some code and look at some some some
demo and what i really want to say is
why rey you know why why rare today is
actually important why do we actually
need another distributed system
and then i'll go ahead and get into the
array architecture how actually the
internal components work and then get
into the design patterns that ray
provides you to write distributed
frameworks
for data scientists and ml and then
we'll look at one of the libraries that
you actually use very often if you're a
data scientist if you're a machine
learning developer you need to train
data you need to tune your data you need
to do hyper parameter optimization and
there are native libraries built on top
of that and then i'll give a demo of of
how you actually see using the extra
boots ray given the time i don't think
i'll get a chance to get into the
exhibit ray but um
i'll have office hours you can come in
and ask me any questions you might
actually have okay so why rey
so before we actually get into you know
what rey is all about
i think the original creators of rey who
were
phd students are guided by yen stoica at
rice lab those of you actually heard
about rice layer brice light was the
successor to amp lab where spark was
born and mesos was born and and cafe was
born a rice label was the ten years
after that this new new emergence of
distributed computing and the creators
of this particular project were looking
at the industry's trends what was
actually happening now what's the next
big thing that actually going to happen
and they realized there were three
fundamental trends of factors that
really affected it one was that we have
sort of entered if i could
uh use the metaphor without being
hyperbolic about it is that we have
entered the zeiss guys of ml right ml is
very progressive in almost every
application today you see almost
everybody is actually talking about ml
from the industry in the finance to the
automotives manufacturing to robotics ml
is everywhere so it's very very
prevalent and one of the things that
actually had led to the prevalence is
that these machine learning models these
machine learning
models which are being produced or or
developed require a very high intensity
compute intensity demand and so the
second trend was that as a result of
this
the distributed computing used to be an
exception before right those of you
actually 10 years ago
were looking at this because there was
an exception only a few people actually
used it today it's actually becoming a
norm it's going to be a necessity
because of this pervasiveness that we
actually see and the result of this is
that we actually have
a need to have this you know compute
intensive ml programs which are being
you know which are being deployed in
this in in these industries and if you
look at the particular trend from 2000
all the way up to currently where we
have very large gpt models being
deployed they actually require a fair
amount of compute intensive and the
problem is that the cpus and the gpus
that we actually produce
cannot really meet the demand right so
the only way we can actually do things
is to actually go uh completely
horizontally we have to actually
distribute gas the gap is not is is not
being filled because of these um systems
actually require a fair amount of
compute intensive and the current
hardware a specialized hardware don't
even meet that so the only way you can
actually do is compute horizontally so
that's sort of the second trend that
actually led to this emergence of of
the distributing computing becoming a
necessity and not a gnome
and then if you look at the the third
one uh those of you who
can attest to that distributed computing
is not easy or if you're actually
building systems it's not very easy to
program in order to actually build them
and the reason is that there are some
trade-offs when you actually think about
how you actually build these systems
right
no presentation is is valid without
having this two-dimensional lens where
you look at one thing on the left and
you look at the thing with x-axis but if
you look at the existing solutions they
exist people actually work and work on
distributed systems they build
distributed system deployed and manage
and monitor it and if you'll actually
look at the middle part
people use this in terms of building
this judgment system where they actually
pick up district parts you know you have
for streaming they might use your uh
spark they might use flank for data
processing you might use another tool
the problem with that is that these are
disparate bespoke tools right they have
different communication protocols they
have used different languages so
stringing them together actually can be
quite a cumbersome task and then if you
actually look at the far right
you have you know you do yourself thing
whereby
um you know not invented syndrome you
have really experts who say well we're
just going to use docker we're just
going to you know slap over things
together now unless you're a large
enterprise and you have you know deep
pockets you might not be able to
actually use that so it's very general
right but it's very difficult to to
maintain and and to to to manage it
because of the fact that you actually
need very deep expertise and then if you
go to the um far left which is most the
easiest one up on the high scale it's
very it's you know it's very easy to use
you know all you all you worry about is
you don't have to worry about managing
clusters it's completely the serverless
you write your bigquery or you write
your lambda function and you just submit
it to the uh to the cluster and let the
cluster manager deal with the resources
and let the cluster manager scale up and
scale down the problem there obviously
is that there's some trade-offs right
you might be beholden to
the the the compute time that that
you're allowed to actually run with it
uh you might not have the persistence
that you might actually require when
you're actually running some serverless
lambda function or a query that you
might require in your subsequent state
so there's no state being mentioned uh
you might be beholden to the fact that
some of the hardware is not available
for you so you are sort of you know um
uh beholden to the to the to the uh the
uh the computer uh uh cloud provider
giving only hardware so all these are
you know different kinds of trade-offs
and you just had to figure out you know
which one you actually use they all work
they all actually have merits and
trade-offs
so what we're thinking
when this creator's a rare chemical only
say well what we can do is i think we
have a solution that we can address
these things and one thing we can
actually do
is that if you look at sliders map if
you look at ray
ray is a way for you to actually run
your system anywhere you can actually
run it on any of the cloud providers um
at the bottom you can actually run your
laptop you can run it on your um
on any of the cloud providers or your
laptop or on premise
and then the second layer if you
actually look at this as a layered cake
of capability and functionality you're
the rare core and the rear core is
really i lost this the ray core is
really your your fundamental
your fundamental abstraction that allows
you to distribute your your primitives
and the rare core apis are the ones that
actually give you this abstraction to do
the distributed computing and one thing
if i can't get away anything you
actually want to walk away with that
this is the ethos and that's the premise
array apis we provide you the
ray api abstractions so which you can
actually build distributed systems and
let ray infrastructure deal with the
computer resources let it deal with
elasticity let it deal with the
performance let it deal with the the the
fault tolerance and if you actually go
one level above
you have the what we call the core
libraries which are built using these
core primitives and then the integration
libraries which are all the common ml
libraries that you actually want to use
that actually
work on ray and if you are a distributed
framework um a programmer who actually
wants to write your own distributed
framework that comes on the far right
right so you can actually build use
these primitives to build that so that's
sort of at a very high level that's what
that's what ray is all about and if you
look at the native libraries these are
the libraries that we actually provide
that run on top of the ray that allow
you to scale your machine learning right
so if you actually want to do huge
amount of data processing you can
actually use modern by the way devin is
going to be giving a talk this evening
he's the creator of modern running on
rey
so attend this talk if you actually find
out how you can actually do pandas on
the distributed scale
if you actually want to do training you
can use distributed training using ray
train
and if you actually want to use serve
you can use race serving and so on and
so forth and if you are the guy who
actually is building models and you need
to do your your hyperparameter tune you
can actually use tune and optuna with
that
and then if you are into reinforcement
learning that's another library that
actually provides so we actually
provided these native libraries for you
to be able to actually do that and then
finally you know who's actually using
this these are all the different
companies who are actually using the
massive scale
and all these companies use it for
different purposes right they
they they use it for
um um
data processing they use it for all
different things
and our approach is that you can
actually take your python programs that
you actually have you can take your
python functions that you have you can
take your python classes that you
actually have
and then scale it using this apis to run
it on the cluster and that sort of is
ray's approach so what i'm going to do
now is drop down a little bit to the the
architecture and what what ray is all
about
and if you look at um
the component of the distributed system
this is no different from any
distributed system that you actually
looked at right you actually have the
working nodes you have
the the head node that actually has a
driver program and the unique thing
about rey which is distinguishing
feature is that you have this
distributed scheduler right if you look
at other distributed systems they have
central place which is the bottleneck
that actually arranges and creates your
dag and then
furnishes or or hashes out the the task
over here you have a distributed
schedule and then you have a distributed
store that that has which keeps a shared
memory of all the objects that you
actually create in your tasks which are
which are crossed across and that's sort
of the fundamental distribution factor
of ray which is actually different from
from anything else
and then
if you go one level below
this is where ray actually distinguishes
itself you got all these different
components they do different things the
worker is the one that actually might
run your task each worker
is associated a bound to a core and so
if you have 12 cores on a machine you
actually can use 12 cores
you have the railet which is the massive
distributed scheduler and that talks to
all the other ray resources to figure
out what what resources how many gpus do
i have how many cpus do i have and based
on that i'll schedule a task to be run
on that it reports all the metadata that
it actually has and what tasks is
running on on in the global store which
is the central place where all the
metadata is kept so
each and every ray led within a certain
amount of time t knows exactly who is
running what and what resources are
available so i can actually make my
intelligence scheduling policies so
that's sort of the the central place
what's actually happening behind the
scenes
and now if i go one level below as i as
i say one of the fundamental principles
array was to provide you with this what
i call design patterns of core primitive
apis so you can actually build
this distributed system you can take
these abstractions and convert them into
a distributed setting so you can
actually do that you can think of ray as
a framework for building other
distributed frameworks
so
design patterns are not something new uh
to us
design patterns are not something new
those were sort of introduced earlier by
the gengo four in the book
that actually told us all about design
patterns and those of you who are
software engineers here know what design
patterns are they are like guardrails
they're like guidelines for you to use
the constructs in the language in a
particular manner so you know python has
reiterators and core routines and and
singletons and so on and so forth and so
ray we provide you these design patterns
that take your ray tasks or you take
your python functions and then convert
them into a parallel task or we actually
also have what we call ray objects so
any of your tasks that actually create
an object we convert them into into a
distributed object which i then returned
you as a future so we can actually run
these very asynchronously and then you
have the stateful actors which those of
you are familiar with arlang or or or
arca
give you the ability to have stateful
microservices which actually run
and then
if you take this particular pattern this
is all it actually does function gets
converted into a task which is scheduled
on on any particular node
a class can be converted into a stateful
actor which is then deployed in a
particular node as a stateful service to
which you can actually talk and then the
distributed object is an immutable
object shared across the entire cluster
in any task which is running that needs
that particular object can access it at
any time and these objects are really
futures
so how does it actually translate it
into code
so if you actually have a function over
here we actually have a read array uh
that actually just takes a file uh and
then returns your numpy array and then
you have another function called uh add
that takes two numpy arrays and adds
them uh all you have to all you have to
do to convert them into a distributed
setting for for ray to use is that you
use the decorator right so if you use
ray dot remote now this is going to be
converted into a task um if you use for
example your class extra class that you
actually have i can just decorate the
radar remote and that converts that into
into into into a stateful service and i
can provide at the time of the
declaration whether i want to use gpus
or whatever with cpus or how many
resources they need or how much memory
that that particular stateful service
services require and in in running them
all you have to do is use the remote um
dot function and then supply the file
name and it's going to be scheduled to
actually run the same thing with the
actor if you actually want to create an
instance of that actor you just say
counter.remote and it actually returns
that and then last time if you actually
want to get the value of the particular
future you can actually see that what
this readout array does just returns
your feature right away right and so
this is actually what happens in in in
real time is that when you invoke
read that array it gets schedule a node
array it creates a graph over there the
second one is going to be on the second
node uh that's going to compute and read
the array and it's going to return you
an entire array already returns you is
your future right it just returns you an
id
and it creates this dallas dynamically
so it's it's executed eagerly
and when you do add remote now those two
features are going to be sent to this
particular ad function and they will
figure out that i might need to get
those id arrays add them together and
then return you back with the array.get
and ray.get is a blocking function that
says okay i'm going to wait for these
tasks to finish or they've already been
finished and i'll just return you the
value so this is what actually ray task
actually does there is also this notion
of distributed object store
and the distribute object stories is is
is the plasma object store which is the
apache aero tables which runs on each
and every store so each and every worker
has each and every node has a shared
memory and if you actually have workers
running on those particular processes
they have access to that so zero copy so
there is not that much of data being
transferred as ipc you got all these
worker slots processing feature running
and they're accessing all the data that
that the tasks actually created on that
particular object store if the object
score runs up memory you put it on on on
and spill it over the disk so that's
sort of the distribute object store and
how it actually works uh
take this particular instance i have
node 1a then i'm actually in a function
called f it's going to return the value
x whatever the x is but x is not
returned what's actually returned is the
future right or where x might be
computed and x is actually stored in its
shared memory then i have a function
called uh g which i'm not sending the
value of x but i'm sending what was
returned by the invocation of remote
function and now i'm actually sending f
now because of the local locality f is
going to be scheduled not on on another
node but it's going to be scheduled on
the same node where the data resides so
i don't have to transfer that particular
data right so there is some note
locality awareness available for my g to
be scheduled to run over there so i
actually can get the data so that's what
that's what g is going to do g is going
to be scheduled over there and i'll head
the data accessible straight from x and
i'll return it back
okay
so that's sort of you know the code
level now what i want to talk about now
is the ecosystem right now if you are a
data scientist if you're a machine
learning program there are three
fundamental workloads that you are
iteratively going to do in developing
your your model one is you're going to
be training the model and the second
then you're going to be tuning the model
and third you're going to be either
serving or inferencing
and ray tune is one of the libraries
which is very common to be very popular
for you to actually scale and do your
hyper parameter tuning and so what is
tune
tune is really a very efficient
machine library
that supports state-of-the-art uh search
algorithms that you actually have
um it is effective because it's running
on ray so if you're actually creating a
lot of trials if you you're creating um
a lot of hyper parameter tune you can
actually distribute those trials across
and that way you don't have to sort of
worry about running this on a single
node you're running it on on either one
machine or you can actually distribute
across it
and it is
it is quite safe because we actually
keep track of all the trails and all the
checkpoints that you actually need and
as i said it actually supports
something wrong with the slides
you can actually run this on a single
node
and use all the cores available or you
can actually schedule it on multiple
nodes that actually has multiple cores
and i think there's some slides actually
missing over here that
shows the the distribution of how it
actually works but that's essentially
what it is and
okay um
so if you if you look at this particular
slide i'm i'm what i'm trying to show
over here is that the the the search
algorithms that ray actually supports
that you can actually plug into your ray
tune to say these are the search
algorithms i want to use optuna or i
want to use grid search or i want to use
something else
if i want to use schedulers i can use
usher i can use vh4 i can use any of
these very smart state-of-the-art
schedulers to figure out how am i going
to do the next trial so that's what sort
of ray tune allows to do and
for those of you are not familiar or new
you know what a hyper-parameter is and
hyperparameters are parameters that you
actually use to influence how the modal
parameters are going to be used and the
modal parameters are the ones that are
going to be learned during the training
so an example of a modal parameter would
be say in a network environment would be
bias or or the um the the weights uh in
the regression model might be
coefficients and the constants and the
hyper parameters are the ones that
actually detect uh how your your model
is going to look like and they are
normally set before you actually start
doing the tuning and before the the
model starts learning or the algorithm
or your or your training function or
your objective function whatever the
function that you do
to create the laws or whatever metric
that you're trying to compute
and that's sort of the distinguishing
characteristics and here's another
example of of your what your
hyperparameter look like
uh the network diagram would be one of
them again i'm missing a picture over
there where your your your condensed
layer or your number of filters or your
number of
max pool layers all these are hyper
parameter tunings that you can actually
use to figure out what is going to be
the most optimal structure for your
network right and so these are the the
hyper parameters now when you have a
large hyperparameter space
uh it does get expensive right it does
get expensive because now you actually
have to
compute over a large uh uh
amount of hyper parameter space uh it's
time consuming because you know you have
a large space what do you do with it uh
it can consume a lot of resources
obviously
if you're doing a gpu and then it has to
be fault tolerant because if you're
doing it over the cluster and something
goes wrong would you do that right you
won't be able to recover from it and so
the way the ray tune gives you that
ability it's got three strategies right
one is
exhaustive search the other one is using
bayesian optimization to make sure that
the trials are run are are good ones and
then the advanced scheduling where you
actually use the scheduler that i
actually talked about earlier and so in
the exhaustive search
it's pretty easy to implement because
exhaustive search is is
you go through a fixed amount of
parameters and you can actually
parallelize those
the only problem is that
it's very inefficient because there's no
way for you to know whether the previous
trial was good or not because the fact
that you know you have no idea how the
previous trial when you just go through
the bad configuration so that's that's
um a bit of a lot of work and the random
search is the same thing you actually
uniformly goes through through a
combination across the linear space of
those random search and you can actually
do that so that's sort of exhaustive
search
for small data sets and for if you're
running it on a single node that
actually works
the second one is bayesian optimization
where you actually
look for
many trials and it's sequential in
manner whereby you only do
the trials which are promising in other
words if the previous trial ran a little
more then you're actually going to build
on that so if you look at this
particular plot over here the the
diagram in the blue are the trials which
are going to be favored for you for them
to run to completion the other ones are
going to be tossed out because you know
they didn't return any good results
yeah obviously the problem is that this
is sequential and the reason is
sequential is because i need the results
of the previous trial to ensure that the
next one that i'm going to schedule is
is going to be a good one now recent
literature actually has uh published
suggests that some of these are are can
be done in parallel so you don't have
you're not dependent on doing the
sequential one and the last and the most
efficient one is what we call early
stopping and what early stopping allows
you to do
is that it's based on what we call
successive highland or hog
algorithms where you start a bunch of
trials
and then at each subsequent run you just
drop the ones which are not going to do
well they're not meeting your metrics
they're not converging so you just drop
them and then this gives you the ability
to do two things one is that you
actually have a large hyper parameter
space and you can go through all of
these and the ones which are not
performing well you just drop them and
then eventually you will come to a place
where you actually have a good
conversions and you can actually use
those and those are the schedulers like
asha and bhpo and those are actually the
schedulers who actually use this
particular successful algorithm
and so how does the um
how does that work with with hyper
parameter tuning it's very simple three
steps right with hyperparameter training
you create a function your training
function that's going to be the the
objective function that you're trying to
minimize
um you you go through the epochs and all
that um you're going to compute your
loss and you're going to always report
the convergence back to the tune so it
knows now
how did this particular trial run you
define your config space which is your
hyper parameter space you do number of
samples and you define your scheduler
and your algorithm that you want and
here i can say okay i want asha to do my
asynchronous
i have an algorithmic as a scheduler and
i'm going to use optiona as my search
algorithms and those are very easy to
plug in so the list of all the
algorithms i gave you 15 plus old
state-of-the-art you can actually just
use that with just declaration that
gives a very simple way of doing that
how does it do that
it's very simple what it will do is tune
will actually go in and create um
the main worker which will now
distribute the training function across
all that
and it's going to launch all these
workers as actors and it's going to
start running those trials and along the
way it's going to report all the metrics
back in the distributed manner so so
that way the tracker or the optimizer or
the orchestra can say do i really want
to do the next one and then this
actually continues doing it um uh
successively and if there's an early
stop that i need to do it's going to go
ahead and repo stop that um
launch a new trial and if if
if trials fail because one of the
workers is is down i'm going to go ahead
and restore that from the checkpoint and
then start running the the stuff again
so that's sort of you know ray train an
idea i don't think we actually have time
to go through the xgboost uh but i'm
going to talk through the demo i do have
office hours after this so if you want
to you know come and talk to me about
this we'll do that so what i'm going to
do is skip over this but just give you
an idea of xc boost ray is the drop in
replacement
for the exhibit ray so if you actually
want to train things in distributed
manner uh it uses the data parallel um
notion of saying i'm going to have a
copy of of the the model across all my
workers and i'm going to use different
data to actually train them and then
report it back to the final model to
that that's what actually boosts ray is
all about and let me just go to
how much time do we hear david
okay good i think this is a good point
so um i'm not going to talk about the
the executes ray because there's a lot
of slides over here but just just just a
brief mention it actually uses
this architecture which is a distributed
manner and so the way it distributes
and computes the gradients per feature
it uses rabbit or reduced tree
to communicate all the radians for each
and every feature that it has
and then you actually have a training
set which is actually then passed over
to to your um to your worker and these
are shards and the and the tracker as
you'll keep track that and it uses the
the communication protocol rabbit which
is the old
rabbit reduced and if you're using gpus
then you can use glue or you can use
nickel to communicate gradients within
the gpu and then one of them is actually
assigned as a rank zero uh to to be the
the main
parameter server and then it just keeps
track of that okay so what we'll do is
we'll just go i'm not going to go
through this because i don't think we
have time
so it actually uses four torrents
in in xc boost so if you're actually
using cold start what it actually does
that if if your array worker is is
running and one of them actually fails
what happens over here is the one that
actually failed loads the particular
data and everything starts so that's
sort of the cold start right that's
that's a very inefficient way the more
warm no
known elastic one is a warm start where
you actually have all the workers
running one of them actually works all
the ones are posed they're not training
they're posed and and the worker that
actually failed just reads the data from
its last checkpoint and then starts
training again and the last one which is
the more elastic one which is uh
the array exhibit array support is the
most efficient one where what happens at
this point when the worker actually dies
what happens at this point is that
all the other workers keep on training
they don't stop right they keep on
training the the
the failed worker loads the data back
and then that continues doing so that
essentially is the um
how this is done what i really want to
get into is the easy way you can
actually use
the simple api right you just need to
change a couple of things if you're
using xgboostray you just import those
parameter execute array
you rate the data mix which is the way
to distribute your data across your
cluster the rare parameters are how you
actually want to distribute this on the
red cluster and
those are the only three lines of code
you need to change and your all execute
ray can now be run on the distributed
manner okay
uh what i'm going to do is quick take
aways over here as i said distributed
computing is isn't is is no is a
necessity now and it's not going to be
it's going to be a norm and our vision
is to make distributed symptom very
simple all you have to do is just use
those parameters and your python
functions can be actually done okay
um let's go to the demo here
quickly
can we stop the demo
well this is happening uh
in parallel in in range fashion let's do
distributed computing any questions that
i can i can ask while while things are
the asynchronous thing is working yeah
good how does ray handle large data sets
when you talk about large data sets in
terms of how it distributes it or how it
actually handles in memory
yeah so this was what 0.8 version array
okay yeah so the most recent one we
actually made quite quite improvements
and so you know how it actually handles
the large datasets is is how much memory
you have obviously because ray data we
have we have introduced this new library
called ray data sets that allows us to
shard this data into partitions and
these partitions are now going to be
stored on the ray plasma store right so
yes it's still going to be stored on on
the red plasma store and you're still
obviously limited by
by by the physical memory which is no
different from say if you using uh spark
right
sparking multiple jobs
yeah i mean
you're going to have in a multi-tenant
environment yes you're going to actually
have have those contending issues but i
believe that would be no different from
any other
uh
yes there is this notion i i talked
about if if there's not enough memory
what happened is that is that the all
the the all object stores which are
still sitting there um they will be
spilled over to the disk and new data
set will be there so there is a way to
actually uh preempt imp those and this
was something that was that was added
recently so if you have a large data set
right that needs to be fit in the memory
and they're all all objects towards
which the reference counts are actually
going down they've expired their the
cache they'll be spilled over to the
disk right
yeah it's much
oh yes oh yes no
no no no no crash
yes you've written c plus plus so you
won't see any core dumps
yeah so deeper lbd right now i mean we
have the the dashboards that live you do
that
you can actually um um i don't know if
you're actually with ray summit we are
working on the distributed debugging
where you can actually do pdb so you can
attach the pdb to your worker
if you actually wanted to do
debugging you can actually run ray in
local mode and then just attach that on
on the cluster so there are two ways to
do that one is we try to make it more
easier where you can actually use
distributed debugging using pdb the
other one is you can actually run it in
in local mode
yes
yeah
yeah yeah well i think i think we are
still primitive everywhere you know
spark has the same problem printf
statements and log files and dashboards
actually help that so um yeah we are we
are ways away
anybody else
are we doing the video we good
oh it's not showing on the projector
okay fine then um we probably
i just entertain more questions and
i'll give you a demo in the office hours
and if you come to the office out and
watch the demo i'll give you a red
sticker not my t-shirt but i'll give you
a rest here
oh yeah thanks uh when you discuss fault
tolerance on one of the slides yeah how
is the checkpointing saved and restored
yeah the checkpoint
checkpoint can be actually saved oh okay
no it's not showing on the it's actually
showing on my on my confidence monitor
it was not showing on my real monitor
anyway what were you saying
previous slides you were you were
talking about fault tolerance you said
that you know if one of the notes
crashed it would restore right how is
the checkpointing actually saved and so
the checkpoint um can be used checkpoint
directory can be one of the paths to
your to your tune parameter and so you
can actually have a local directory
where it's checkpointed or you can
actually put it on s3 right so depending
on what what uh cloud provider you're
actually using it's just the path that's
that's writable and you can checkpoint
how often you actually want you want
checkpoint per epoch you want checkpoint
per uh uh you know
based on on the certain callbacks so
there's a certain callbacks associated
with ray tune that you can say for this
particular checkpoint i want the
frequency of the checkpoint to be done
great thank you
any other going once
twice
all right well thank you a lot um sorry
i couldn't uh we couldn't we couldn't
get the demo sorted out but i have it on
my laptop so i'm having office hours
after this do stop by
and thank you very much for your
attention